[MUSIC PLAYING]
How do you define AI?
Oh, that's a controversial
question, I feel like.
This is a pretty hard question.
I think AI is definitely
an overloaded term,
even amongst researchers
who supposedly research AI.
AI-- artificial intelligence--
is the idea that we
can teach a computer
to replicate some things,
or eventually all things
that humans consider
intelligence.
I think the term AI gets
a little bit overloaded,
especially in the news.
So for me, when
most people say AI,
they actually mean
machine learning,
which is just a pattern
recognition from seeing
a whole bunch of previous data.
I think AI is the culmination
of any sorts of techniques that
allow computers to
solve complicated tasks
without humans having to
manually specify solutions
or really precise algorithms.
AI is, essentially, I like
to think of intelligence
as the ability to
process information
to inform future
decisions, and AI
is the ability to build
artificial algorithms
to do exactly that.
Process information to
inform future decisions.
I'm still trying to
figure that one out.
Yep.
[MUSIC PLAYING]